[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
that is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing actual
relationships we're glad you're with us
christina ellis ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five triple eight
eight two five five two two five
starting off this hour's emily in
nashville hi emily welcome to the ramsay
show
hey dave how are you today great what's
up in your world
i'm doing good um i just have a question
i am the trustee of an estate i've got
everything liquidated but the final
piece of property and i've got a cash
offer but i'm not sure if i should take
it or not okay
what do you think the value of the
property is appraisal
well we weren't able to get an appraisal
because it's commercial property what do
you think it is worth
what do you what do you estimate the
value to be
i don't really know because the the
realtors told me anywhere from 375 to
650 is what i should expect for it um
i mean you can throw a hand grenade and
hit that
it's a bit of a range what is this what
kind of property is it um so it used to
be a flea market um it's closed now so
now it's 15 and a half acres
um
and so it's it's basically it's a little
weird situation of there's not a lot of
road frontage and half of the property
still has woods on it
and so
it's three and a half acres zone
commercial
uh 15 and a half 15 and a half acres
zone commercial yes where is it
this is up in ohio oh okay
okay and so basically it's raw ground i
mean the flea market was just
they stood up some tables and stuff
right
um there is three structures i've got a
big barn a storage unit building and
then a walk-through pavilion um they're
all cleaned out and empty
and then so is this is this zoned
commercial in a metro area or what
um it's
it's not exactly metro but it's not
rural it's like an up and coming area
and its own commercial
correct yes okay so what would it be
used for so if i were to buy it it's a
piece of basically a raw ground i'm not
you don't need a barn on a commercial
property you're going to mow this thing
down you're going to build something in
there you're going to build a mall on
that strip mall on that am i going to
build a transmission center am i going
to
uh put a fast food joint on it what am i
going to do with it
it's really whatever you'd
do you think it's going to be used for
but i like to
i mean if i was in ohio i would use it
for storage units myself but
some developers come in and gotcha okay
all right so you listed it for how much
we listed at 650. and what do they offer
you
um we're at 550 now is what we've
dropped down to and they offered me
originally 400 and i got him up to 415
but he he won't come any higher
okay so
the bottom line is we don't know
we know this is under asking but asking
was a wild guess
on value yes because we really don't
have anything in this conversation or in
conversations you've had to establish
value right
correct yes
emily how long has it been listed
so when it was my grandparents property
they've had it up and off the market for
15 years i listed it myself in march
and i have a six-month contract with the
realtors i have right now
i'm just part of the concern is they're
dual realtors so they're doing my side
and the other side so i don't
i don't have the most uh excitement that
they may be giving me the best advice on
if i should take this offer or not
okay
uh
tell me if i'm wrong when i say this
is a difficult piece of property
yes it's very difficult very unique
limited market
limited road frontage
uh your grandparents tried to sell it um
now some guy comes along and he's
establishing value for whatever reason
he's going to use it for
i have no idea what it's worth um
in this scenario i can't get a gauge on
it based on our conversation
so it's hard for me to uh do this uh
it does feel like there is a value to
getting rid of something that appears to
be hard to sell
it does feel like there's a value to
uh
putting a bow on this estate and being
done with it everybody got their money
we walk away
uh
it doesn't sound like you're leaving 200
000 on the table i don't believe that
based on what you're telling me do you
i don't think i am um it's just it's i
just have a hard time believing the
market has shifted so much from january
when i got some of the first numbers
from the market analysis
to now well the market analysis was 375
to 650
yeah it's not exactly a narrow range
yeah i mean if it was six and a quarter
to 650
well we've actually got something that
indicates value but 375 to 650 doesn't
indicate value that's just somebody
can't find a comp and we're guessing
yeah
i mean i
you know uh
based on the two things i said before
i'm probably taking it because i like to
simplify my life
okay
okay but i i can't i'm not doing that
because i'm
assured
of the value i don't i really don't
think what you're telling me is you're
leaving 200 grand on the table you've
had no offers in 15 years
you know before with grandma trying to
sell it and now you're putting it on the
market and
and we can't establish value and it's an
unusual piece of property in a not so
booming
uh street it's got limited
uh street frontage
uh yeah there's just a lot here it's a
bit of a white elephant property in that
sense
and so yeah i'm probably just gonna cut
cut bait and move on to the next thing
if it's me i just i like simple and
predictable and
low risk and
you know would you buy this piece of
property for 415 000 no
so you're going to buy it again if you
don't take this you bought it back yeah
since well is that a conflict of
interest for the real estate agent to be
representing both sides is that normal
very normal not unusual at all um
especially when it's disclosed uh
because the thing is this um
you know they've disclosed what's called
a dual agency but you know it's just
assuming people have
uh integrity if you don't think your
real estate agent has integrity then
then you shouldn't have them anyway no
matter what but
um
you know they
they told her 375 to 650 that's
not even
i could just make stuff up like that too
and i didn't even sing the property you
know i mean it's just it's such a range
that yeah wow that's amazing the real
estate market is uh officially slowing
down
uh and it's not a bad thing because it
was so wide hot that every piece of
property went on the market was a dead
gum auction
and that's not healthy for the market
that's not healthy economics
so it's slowing down to where the buyer
demand is more attuned to
seller availability inventory supply
versus demand but demand is still
greatly over supply so if you have a
traditional piece of property you're
going to list you're not going to take a
beating on value
but you are going to not sell it with 85
offers over the weekend
uh we're already seeing that slow down
in a recession for towards the recession
or on almost recession or
whatever we're going to call this thing
statistically but
the market has slowed down not a bad
thing you still sell a house reasonably
still buy a house reasonably
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest-serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
so
[Music]
christina ellis number one best-selling
author
ramsey personality is my co-host today
guys this building wealth tour that we
have our live event tour is blown up on
monday we announced a sellout for
phoenix on september the 13th and we
launched uh the following or the day
before in phoenix september the 12th as
a second show and it almost sold out
half in 24 hours so going crazy and
today we're announcing that the
sacramento event november the 1st is
officially sold out
as well and as i told you uh yesterday
we can't get uh extra uh venues in these
other cities so there won't be second
shows on those
so uh that means we have now september
12th phoenix available we have
minneapolis november 10th available and
san antonio november 15th available but
i'm warning you all three of those are
going to be gone shortly
so if you want tickets quit screwing
around go get your tickets now's the
time
25 tickets or you can get a four pack as
low as 60 dollars and that means you can
bring a whole group of friends for what
you pay for pizza
uh yeah this is a deal and it's going to
be george camel
rachel cruz dr john dolony ken coleman
and me will be taking pictures signing
books
and uh answering questions doing all
kinds of things it's going to be an
incredible incredible event in these
different cities in the red hot the
building wealth tour and get your
tickets at ramseysolutions.com
uh while the gettin's good washington dc
is on the line david's with us hi david
welcome to the ramsey show
hey david christina it's great to talk
with you you too what's up
so um i understand why target date
mutual funds are not a good idea for my
retirement account because as you
explain i'll need the money to last for
30 years past my retirement date i think
that makes a lot of sense but my
question is would target date funds be a
good idea for my kids 529 accounts i
have a four year old and a seven week
old and because i don't need the money
for
specific four-year windows it feels
different than that 30-year timeline you
always talk about so i'm wondering what
you think about that target date funds
in a 529 account
well so here's what happens in a target
day fund they shift the portfolio
as the quote date arrives
to be more and more conservative as you
understand david correct
right yeah okay so the answer to the
question the math is not going to be
nearly as dramatic in college as it is
in retirement number one because there's
not many years too up to the date
involved and not as many years after the
date involved your point this is only
four years okay
so
if you were to run the math and say i
stayed
by by definition if you do what we teach
being the four types of mutual funds are
just a good growth stock mutual fund
your more aggressive stance doing that
than doing a target date agreed
that's correct yeah okay and so if you
stay in a more aggressive up until that
four year mark
even at the date of the first semester
you don't cash the whole thing in
you're only cashing enough to go to that
semester
right right and so were the market to be
down
you could only cash in one semester and
even if it isn't down
you're going to ride out and you're only
going to take the money out as you need
it so you've got a four-year spread to
ride any market variations number one
which is the reason to get more
conservative because you can't stomach
the variation
mathematically right and so here what's
going to happen is you're going to make
less
using a target date than you will using
a straight growth stock mutual fund
because you're going to earn an
aggressive amount all the way up until
and through the time that you take the
money out
now the downside potentially is that uh
that the market went down and stayed
down four years
at the exact wrong time
which would be like a record event
so i didn't do that in other words i
just bought mutual funds
because of that concept right there uh
it it comes down to timing the market
number one
number two um uh the other so you'll
make less if you use the target but
you're taking less risk
maybe
maybe
yeah and congrats on the new baby that's
seven weeks old four years old you're
getting on baby step five these babies
are going to be set up for success
especially asking these questions and
really thinking about where you're
investing in the portfolio yeah in
to christina's point you you know the
fact that you actually are aware of all
of this and bothering
is the answer to the equation not the
difference in target versus growth the
difference in target versus growth is
almost
two guys arguing over a cup of coffee
about something it really doesn't matter
much okay it'll matter some and so what
i addressed kind of was the theory right
but the actual dollar change in the
situation
98 of the dollar change in the situation
is because you're a good dad
right and you're addressing this
you know two percent
is the difference between target and
the difference in these two things if
you do a target or i do is neither in
either case is the kid not going to go
to school because of this
because because we've got a stud dad
who's stepping up and doing his job here
and taking care of business to your
point right a lot of people with a seven
week old are just trying to focus on how
much sleep they can get
oh you got me too
that's a fair thing to focus on by the
way uh spoken like a grandpa who keeps
them occasionally all right megan is in
nashville hi megan welcome to the ramsay
show
hi how are you dave and christina great
what's up
okay so i just graduated from undergrad
debt free and i have about 8 000 in my
emergency fund
and i'm about to start my phd next month
and the program is fully funded
and additionally they pay us a stipend
of 35 000 a year so essentially i'm
getting paid to pursue my degree sad gun
girl get it girl yeah what are you
studying
uh so i actually met you a couple days
ago it's a phd in the biomedical
sciences
it's an interdisciplinary program the
first year and then you specialize well
you're so dadgum smart they're paying
you to go there you're amazing
it's a good gig fellowship deal huh
what was that is it a fellowship
so the first year i think it's just paid
for by the school and then depending on
what lab you join then like those grants
that go towards the research are also
paying their phd students what are you
going to do with your life
um so i'd like as of now i do
like academia like being a research
scientist teaching while also being a
scientist at a university
i think that's going to be perfect yeah
yeah it sounds appealing to me right now
but there's also different things like
in industry and government and all types
of different jobs that you can oh yeah
yeah i was just interested what your
goal was this is very cool because
you're obviously unbelievably bright
congratulations very well done well
thank you thank you i think her purse is
smarter than me so but yeah um
but yeah uh so
what's your question then is what
okay so after building up my emergency
fund to 15 000 which is my goal right
now
it seems like my next step would be to
begin investing into retirement 15
but i did meet with the smart investor
pro and he recommended
not to do so because i am in school
until like first start investing a
non-retirement account um because he
said it was important to keep my money
liquid especially that i'm in school
good i understand this is usually the
advice good answer that is usually the
advice yeah
but i for some reason i feel like i'm in
a different situation than you know an
undergrad student because
the program's fully funded and
additionally i'm being paid so to me it
doesn't seem very different than if i
were to get a job right after undergrad
so my question is like once i do
fully fund my emergency fund what should
i do with the leftover money that i have
yeah the the difference is you're a
glorified intern now when you graduate
you're going to be making bank
so this is not like your big girl job i
mean
so
you know i'm going to err on the side of
safety in this case you have so much to
concentrate on to go through a phd
program that is a rigorous process
particularly at vandy
and uh and you're you're up to the
you're up to the challenge you can do it
but i don't want you concentrating on
money
once you concentrate on finishing this
phd and then the money will come
yes and and all that yeah because if
you're screwing around over here with
investments on the side you got your
brain half
into this stuff i i'm gonna stick with
what the smart investor pro said because
he said what i told him to say by the
way which is when you're in college pile
up cash you are the best possible
investment invest in yourself even
though you're not having to pay for
anything here i got that uh but this is
just your safety net to make sure you
finish this because i can't think of
anything more important than you
finishing this
in your world it's a big deal it's good
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you
shop their latest looks and see how much
you can save at blinds.com today the
easy and affordable way to make your
home more beautiful is blinds.com
[Music]
christina ellis ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today
drop by the ramsey solutions
headquarters anytime you'd like we do
this radio show this podcast this
youtube event whatever you want to call
this thing the ramsay show for three
hours every day from 1-4 central time
and uh lots of folks as they're
traveling somewhere else
drop by here on their way to whatever
their destination is and just hang out
for a little while watch the show happen
and
there's free coffee homemade cookies and
uh we've got a whole visitor center and
the show is done on the glass so you get
to watch us do this
which
is questionable but you do get to watch
it and we don't charge you for it so if
you don't like it we can just cut our
pay in half but you know but either way
and in the lobby where all this happens
is a stage we built when we built this
building for debt-free screams justina
is on that stage how are you justina i
am fantastic dave how are you better
than i deserve where do you live i am
from manchester new hampshire welcome to
nashville thank you welcome good to have
you now how much debt have you paid off
i've paid off 271
819
goodness
and your how long did this take 38
months wow
very long months and you're yeah
your range of income during this time
started at about 105 000 and went up to
187 000.
okay what do you do for a living i am a
physician assistant oh pa
okay all right good for you and so based
on uh that information i'm gonna guess
and say that was student loan debt yes
sir
wow had a couple little ankle biters had
some medical debt um had some personal
loans some credit cards but 255 000 was
sallie mae's eviction notice so you're
what 28 28 yes i'm guessing but that's
about what the numbers would tell me
good good stuff well done amazing so you
came out of school big old pile of
student loans intimidating as crud but
you've got the ability to create a big
shovel as a pa
and uh you went after it you've been
working your tail end off all through
covet and everything else here and you
knock this thing out tell us the story
what inspired you to do that how did you
get connected to us
what's the what's the backdrop yeah so i
actually was living in fantasyland when
i graduated um i was told by a bunch of
broke people i took financial advice
from that i would be fine because i was
going to have a great income so i kind
of ignored the fact that i had student
loans
i
i knew i had them i didn't look at the
number and when i got my first paycheck
as a pa i went out to a very fancy
dinner enjoyed myself greatly
and then a couple weeks later the
interest on my student loans capitalized
and i gained about forty thousand
dollars just in um interest oh nice and
then that made me look at the balance
and when i saw that it crossed over a
quarter of a million dollars i went oh
that's a problem
yeah it felt honestly that was the
moment that it felt like i got punched
in the stomach yeah
and
i thought okay i don't know that this
great fantastic income that i work so
hard for is going to get me out of this
anymore
um you know scared you it did
very badly and you know just a few weeks
after that um you know i had a really
great paycheck and ended up cashing out
a uh coin jar to get a tank of gas
and that was the never again moment for
me
i said something has to change so
i in a panic googled how in the world do
i pay off these student loans as fast as
possible and honestly i was looking for
the magic pill the secret the
um you know the the quick answer to
write you a script right exactly exactly
you know i wanted the the quick answer
the forgiveness whatever i could do
um to get them gone as fast as possible
and that's when i found a youtube video
of somebody else doing a debt-free
scream um who was in a very similar
situation to me and i thought oh that's
just one off you know it's just that
that one person and then all of a sudden
there was another and another and
another and i thought okay well all
these people are doing this
uh i i can too yeah there's nothing
special about them
i can do it too
it's a lot of hard work yeah so what
kind of things did you do to get out of
debt you obviously have a great income
was that all your primary job did you do
side hustles what'd that look like so
part of that income jump is changing
jobs so i actually moved from
connecticut up to new hampshire so i had
a job change
which helped a little bit but i kept the
job in connecticut
because the pay was very good during
covid
so i was actually commuting from new
hampshire down two states away
for a side hustle
um so i would work my regular job during
the week i would go down there on the
weekends i would work extra shifts and
then on my primary job i was also
picking up overtime on call shifts
overnight
i was doing anywhere from you know 60 to
80 hours on average my
record was 127 hours
in one week
so it was just a lot of hours a lot of
hours yeah
yeah so the the you because all of this
is right in the middle of covid yes sir
and so the 38 month lands right over the
top of that so
uh
sadly that actually helped your income
it did there was no shortage of hours i
desperately needed your help yes yeah
and there was a shortage of every type
of medical personnel at that time and so
uh uh wow
wow
did your co-workers think you were kind
of crazy oh yeah absolutely oh yeah
oh yeah
absolutely no question
they all have a touch of the docitis as
you like to say yeah so nobody was doing
what i was doing yeah
are you glad you did it oh yeah oh yeah
i feel to be free
it's a weight off i mean it
it's indescribable honestly it's i feel
like i can breathe again yeah i don't
owe anything to anybody nobody's coming
after me yeah if we take this 38 months
and
make that the the beginning of that be
the beginning of a 10-year period after
10 years you're going to be so far
financially ahead of
the docs who did not do this yeah
because now you've got a 200 000 income
basically with no debt yep and you've
got the ability to build wealth the
ability to be generous uh the ability to
make choices in your career you're not
trapped
by some program you're not trapped by
some kind of golden handcuffed process
that's all tied to the student loan debt
you've got the you know and every one of
those things are going to cause you to
go crazy this is amazing you did so good
yeah
she's powerful this is incredible this
is so powerful and especially right now
for people listening there's so many
people that are feeling anxiety about
the student loan moratorium ending and
they think the same thing you know i got
a great job i don't have to worry about
this
about paying it off i'm just going to
carry these loans around forever what
would you tell those people it's
the mental aspect of it
you know it's the fact that i can go to
sleep at night and i know that i owe
nothing to anybody and
bigger than that the last couple of
years has been a huge behavioral change
for me i am completely different person
than i was three years ago in what way
i am much more intentional both with my
money and both and with the decisions
that i make in my everyday life i mean i
think before i was kind of just
floating through life and i was letting
life happen to me
and now i take value in
taking control over my life
yeah it's interesting the empowerment
part of being empowered to take over
this money thing and beat this debt down
tells you i can do this in other areas
it tells you i i actually have more
control of things than i like to think
and people like to think so let me ask
you about something else that just
popped into my head i'm just really
curious basically during covid you were
working
a bizarre number of hours
and there was a period of those months
where
i'm guessing even you didn't know what
you were running into i mean you're in a
sense you were running into a burning
building every day
uh because you know after a while we
began to get data and we began to
realize the situation and some of the
stuff was overblown and there was a lot
of drama on covet but in the early days
of that the medical professionals were
you had to think i may be taking my life
in my hands
you adapt
you'd have to
but you weren't going into those
situations for money you were going to
those situations because you're a
healthcare professional yeah that's what
i wanted words in your mouth but i
assume
yeah that's the profession that i chose
and that's the life that i that i chose
and
yeah i love what i do because because a
lot of put into anything else
there's a number of not a lot of i don't
say i don't know what the number is but
there's a number of people in that
world
who just chose to not go
so well done we're proud of you it's
amazing young woman we got a copy of
baby steps millionaires and all the
other books for you 272 000 paid off in
38 months making 105 to 187 justina from
manchester new hampshire count it down
let's hear a debt free scream
three two one
ah
if i go into a hospital and i need a pa
i hope she's there
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
christina ellis ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five
two two five john is with us in
jacksonville florida hi john welcome to
the ramsey show
thanks dave and christina i really
appreciate you taking my call um
the question is um probably not typical
but i'm part of a church board that's
pretty conservative and has
managed to
get themselves out of debt and carry no
debt
unfortunately we're in the middle of a
voting period of deciding whether or not
to do a church remodel and the majority
of the board is
comfortable with
obtaining a one million dollar loan to
conduct this
church remodel and
obviously i'm not
i've shared
my opinions i've shared proverbs 22 7
with them and lots of other things i've
learned from you
but i was just wondering if you had any
guidance on
maybe
trying to come up with a resolution
well um
there's a lot of factors at play here
um
i've been in these situations myself um
a couple times
um
number one uh
you don't and i don't believe that debt
is a sin according to the bible
i hope you don't i don't yeah and i i um
[Music]
but i also can't find a single time in
scripture god used debt to do his work
larry burkett used to say that the
there's no no time in scripture
that the amalekites had the israelites
him down in the getting ready to kill
him off in the in in the uh uh in the
canyon and so they did a bond issue
it's just not in there they ran down the
banking alone it's not in there there's
no time there's no positive reference to
that in scripture and so biblically
speaking
debt is stupid but it's not a sin
it's just dumb right okay now you got a
group of people disagree with that on
your board obviously
um you've got to reconcile several
different things so you've covered that
issue with them already
um
and
and again i'll quote larry burkett
because he's who taught me a lot of
these things in the especially from a
christian viewpoint or biblical
viewpoint
um
he used to say that too often the church
board looks more like the chamber of
commerce than anything else because it's
people in the church uh
usually men
who are successful business people in
the community and so the pastor and the
congregation looks to the successful
business people to run the business and
the governance of the church and so it's
not unusual for your church board to be
a banker a car dealer an insurance agent
or whatever on there and and so and the
problem with that is uh they bring their
best ideas
and think that they are the truth rather
than i mean you got a banker on there
that you know rather than
what does scripture say
and so where i think and apparently you
think the scripture ought to be the
baseline the plum line by which we make
these decisions
and so um
uh then that brings up a couple things
all right then that brings us down to
they're gonna do it anyway right
right well
we're going to vote on it and decide
yeah we haven't voted yet i mean if you
can if you can persuade enough of them
to use the biblical plumbline
rather than their professional training
to make this analysis which is what
should be done then you can probably
talk them out of it but i
it a lot of times you can't
and i've got you know i've had been in
those situations where the guys i'm
arguing with are friends of mine but
they're just wrong
uh
and so then you've got to decide a
couple things number one i would never
tell someone in a congregation
to leave a church
just because the church took on debt
i'm femininely against it but again i
don't think it's a sin i just think it's
stupid
and if you leave a church every time you
disagree with something the church does
you're gonna be in a different church
every week
because there's always some part of
church is you get to disagree
i mean that's just all you just count on
being upset about something
and if not somebody will make up
something to be upset about and so the
times you should leave a church is when
you have uh lost hope in the integrity
or the wisdom
of the leadership
and the only time i have left the church
is over that where i've lost hope in the
integrity of the leadership or i've lost
hope in the path that they're on i just
cannot align with that but it's never
over a single thing
uh with you know it could be over a a
doctrinal issue or something else but
it's never over a single
event like
okay i left because they did this
remodel i i would not tell you to do
that
i would though
it would be hard for me to sit in
leadership
on this board if they're going to go in
against something that is a core tenant
of my life because i'm going to then be
endorsing in a sense my presence if i
stay on this board i'm going to be
endorsing what i believe to be something
that is very very wrong direction
uh again it's not an integrity issue
it's not a salvation issue and that kind
of thing and i'm not telling you to
resign i'm just sharing with you where
my heart is in other words if you were a
congregate i would just say vote against
it make your best case
and then suck it up and if there's no
other reason no other problems with this
church it's still your church
but the fact i'm sitting on this board
says that this has my
name on this stupidity
and i can't
i would struggle with that but
to be very clear though i am not telling
you to do that john and it's one of the
reasons i don't sit on boards i'm on
zero boards
non-profit or otherwise
i don't sit on boards because i'm a
horrible board member because i'm right
and you're wrong i really don't have any
other gear
okay and so that's a weakness of mine
and a strength of mine uh and i don't
want to impugn that upon you you're
probably a more reasonable person john
you said the church is debt-free
currently right
correct yeah and i wanted to
yeah i'm sorry go ahead how did they get
debt-free have they is it just an older
church that's never had debt or was
there any type of initiative to become
debt free uh no they've paid off their
debt and and we've been debt-free
probably for a few years and we do have
some reserves and and my proposal is not
to have absolutes like they've said it's
not yes we do the project but no we
don't how about we do the project in
stages
there is a gc that um
proposed to the church and came up with
these excuses why you don't want to do
that and i'd like to hear if dave has an
opinion since he just finished that
major project um
but that
that was kind of my approach and after
listening to the gc i not only wanted to
take a shower like dave says i want to
watch myself with bleach too so um
which is another problem that gotta need
to be that guy you don't trust the guy's
integrity you don't think he's got the
best interest of the client you think
he's got the best interest of his own
pocket
right exactly you're hiring the wrong
guy even if you do the rehab
that's a separate issue one more problem
but but the uh but yeah it can
definitely be done in stages any
construction project can be other stages
is it less convenient yes it's less
convenient
is it um
you know but i you know if i was a
leadership team i would just go before
the church and go hey guys this remodel
is something that'll help the cause of
the kingdom we can we'll be able to have
more people in here we'll be able to
lead more people to christ we'll be able
to disciple them better it's a good move
spiritually for us to do this uh you
guys need to start writing some checks
so we can do it right and i think it
helps to have those people that were
involved in the last initiative to pay
off debt tell their stories i was
recently on my
church board before we moved and we went
through a whole initiative where our
church paid off debt and then of course
board members change out after a few
years and it was nice to have some of
the older board members who had been
through so much of the financials of our
church and have been through they've got
the battle wounds of what it was like to
you know have the stress of being on a
board that's not debt-free and some of
the challenges that comes with that
what's the total budget on this church
john
uh right now they're seeing 400 plus 400
thousand dollars
you know not but they're in the green
400 000. what's the top line what's the
top line
you mean of your total annual income at
this church
well i don't know have those exact
numbers
and you're on the board
yeah i don't have them in front of me i
don't know i mean is it 7 million is it
a million what is it no no no yeah it
probably would be a million somewhere in
that range yeah okay well let me give
you another statistic working with 50
000 churches
you're taking on so much debt
there's an 82 percent chance your pastor
is going to be gone in 36 months
because you're getting ready to strain
this congregation
the pastor fallout with new debt within
36 months is when it's a huge amount of
debt and ratio to their revenues
is
it's massive because you're getting
ready to strain the whole system don't
do this please don't let them do this
please you're going to mess up a whole
good thing oh my gosh
i don't think you can stop them though
it's a runaway train this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
have you been inspired to make a change
with your money want to know where to
start take our three-minute money quiz
to get a plan you can follow go to
ramsaysolutions.com and search for get
started to get a plan for your money
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work they
love and create actual amazing
relationships christina ellis ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author is my co-host today open phones
at
825-5225
daryl is in new york city to start off
this hour hi daryl how are you
hi dave i'm good
thanks for taking my call sure what's up
so um my my wife and i uh we're in
contract to
um buy a new apartment and we're trying
to
tell our old apartment but we're having
a tough time
selling it so we're kind of sitting with
a couple of options
and in order to raise the money to do
the closing
um so we can either slash the price
of our apartment and just like take a
loss on it
i have an inherited ira for my mom
that i can liquidate and pay tax on in
order to fund it and my wife has some
stock options that are investing in
november
that we can possibly use but it wouldn't
cover all of it it would cover about
half
so just trying to or we can just walk
away actually because um there's a cause
in the contract that would give us the
ability to kind of walk away from the
new apartment
you're not gonna like my answer daryl
oh boy
um you're forcing
yourself into a corner
if you own two properties
because you refused to deny yourself
the new one
so
either your house sells or you've cut
bait
got it got it
what is your current property on the
market for
uh we we put it on for um 825.
um what is it what is it actually worth
i mean
what would some goob give for it but
what's it actually worth
i i would say probably about um 750 for
being realistic about it okay so you
were fishing for a sucker fish
yeah there's this with 421a abatement in
new york city where property taxes i
know i know but you're but you were
fishing for it's not even with the
abatement it's worth 750.
yeah yeah
and so what we're really saying is
because i won't try to sell my current
property for what it's actually worth
uh i want to get i want to get a premium
above what it's worth then i've got to
look at am i cashing out something and
creating a taxable situation or am i
going to borrow money or what am i going
to do now cut your property to what it's
worth and sell the stupid thing and if
it doesn't sell let the other one go
okay that's what i would do
it's uh but what i am just describing is
very emotional
because what i just did is i stuck a pen
in your little dream
and blew it up
yeah and it's hard because i i mean i
use my inheritance to make the deposit
so just loot like you're gonna lose that
i thought you said you had an out in the
contract
well i know well
um to to put the deposit when i
originally bought this home it was 150
000. i got some life insurance and uh i
use that as a downpipe the down payment
on this property no you didn't do a down
payment because you're closed on it you
mean you put up an earnest money of 150
000
no the the the property the property we
own now the new one we saved and and put
the money we saved all our bonuses and
things
to put the down payment on that i'm just
talking about the one that we own now
you don't have a down payment on
something unless you own it have you
already closed on the second property
no we haven't closed on it okay then
it's not a down payment it's an earnest
money all the equity yeah the equity
that we have in this in this apartment
is the inheritance i put in basically
on the current one
that's what i'm saying
okay let's separate the two for a second
you have a contract on the second deal
that has a contingency in it that allows
you to not close correct
that's right you would not lose your
deposit on that property if that
contract has that kind of contingency
that's correct okay so you're going to
get all that money back
if you don't close
and you'll be living in your original
property and that is heartbreaking
because your mind and your sweet tooth
is already set on the new place
agreed that's right okay now i agree
what did you pay for the current
property that you are living in
um 765 and then we we redid the kitchen
for 25 000. okay so you've got almost
800 in it but it's not worth that
that's right okay so you're going to
lose your kitchen remodel money but
you're not going to lose 150 000
by selling the same thing for 750 or
760.
yeah it's just a lot of fewer brokers
and all that stuff but yeah
yeah i will walk away with something it
just won't be like you know what we
wanted so
what you wanted was more than it was
worth
yeah
so what you wanted was unrealistic how
long have you owned your current
apartment
and we bought in 2017 so it's been about
four years four or five years
okay
what's your household income
we're at about 530 000. way to go man
um
i you can do what you want to do you
called here and asked so i'm obligated
to answer
number one i wouldn't close on the deal
unless the other one's gone under any
circumstances
number two there's a whole lot of things
i'm hearing in this conversation that
makes me think you impulsed your butt
off on this second purchase
and now you're stuck in it and you're
emotionally stuck in it
um i think it might be
likely is
wise
for you to just cancel the other deal
and enjoy your current million dollar
property for a little while
and sit there and make 550 and pile you
up a big old pile of cash let the value
of that thing come on up a little more
so you're not having to hold your nose
when you sell it
live in it another year two and then
make a move on a much more wise more
solid footing than you're making right
now i think y'all were out wandering
around one day and saw an open house and
bought a house that's what it feels like
yeah and especially with his income he
could probably save up to a really a
lost position pretty quickly those stock
options come in a lot of other things
come in you're forcing this
you're forcing it
it's all over it and it feels very
impulsive
feels very um
it doesn't feel like it was executed
with a plan
and
so i i would not tell you under any
circumstances to own both of these
properties so one of them has got to go
you need to get the one you're living in
sold and just bite the bullet and say
that's it i really want the other one so
badly my wife really wants the other one
so badly that i'm willing to lose
whatever i lose on that and i'm out of
there and i'm going to go buy the other
one
um and then we're going to keep making
550 we're going to get the stock options
we'll get it paid off pretty quick
you're going to be in good shape either
way
but it won't hurt you to sit in this one
another 18 to 24 months and look for
another deal
it won't at all it won't at all but i
would never tell i never tell people to
buy two houses at once to own two houses
at once this happened one of one foot on
the boat one on the dock the dock's
leaving your butt's going to get wet
that's what's gonna happen you're gonna
fall in
and that man i've watched that for 30
years happen over and over and over
again
and you could get away with a lot of
that stuff when the market was quite hot
and crazy like he listed that thing at
white hot crazy prices the auction
prices and didn't get it
those days as we can tell are starting
to go away
thanks for the call
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard
go to netsuite.com ramsey right now to
get their free white paper jump start
your cfo career
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay i don't know new york city values
and what they have done i have not
looked at them other than new york's
expensive market no kidding manhattan
but how that condo apartment co-op
whatever he's in there
from 2017 to now did not go up in value
i'm struggling with that and christina
caught that she's at the break going why
didn't that thing go up in value so um
uh
something wrong something different
about those numbers or that situation
that we didn't understand probably
but the principle still stands you know
in the last two years you have been able
to buy another house knowing that yours
would sell over the weekend
because the market was so white hot if
you simply put it on the market it would
begin an auction process and it would be
gone with 85 offers in five days right
or four four minutes or whatever
uh that those days appear to be gone
which i think as i've said before is
good
um
and so now you've got to put a house on
the market for what it's actually worth
not for what you think some sucker will
give you for it
and it's probably not going to bring
anything except what it's worth
and if i'm asking him this thing's worth
750
but he's going to lose money on it
because he bought it for a brown 750 in
2017 it never went up in value most
markets in america the a property worth
750 since 2017 has gone up 300 300 000
or 400 000
so there's something weird about those
numbers christina mentioned that at the
break yeah that's strange especially
with everything that's been happening in
the housing market but it is interesting
seeing things turning now and it not
being so white hot i think that's
probably a good thing for everything to
kind of balance out
yeah
for people to be able to actually you
know have to not have to have a panic as
they buy things but for
27 of the 30 years that i've been on the
air
if you were going to
buy another property you had to know
that it was going to take some time to
sell yours and it was contingent upon
and you could enter into two deals
if you had the money to do the down
payment and qualify for the other
mortgage you could end up owning two
properties which what that always ends
up doing is putting a strain on your
finances and then you become
on your first property you become what's
known as a motivated seller and you will
give the sucker away
that's 27 of the last 30 years now again
in the last
year or so it's moving back that
direction but there's about a two-year
pocket in here where you could buy a
house
without a contingency on the sale of
yours knowing that you put yours up for
sale it was gonna sell because no
everything's an auction everywhere it's
just crazy but that that un
realistic market is gone number one in
most cases
number two you can't let what you can
pull off in an unreasonable market
become a way of doing business because
that unreasonable market was covering up
for
your risk your stupidity
because you could have got caught with
one foot on the boat one on the dock so
prices aren't going down we don't see
that
we don't haven't seen except for some
rare market situations individual market
situations nationwide we're seeing
prices hold steady uh all projections
are that 2022 they're going to go up
about eight percent nationwide they went
up 18 last year and 29 the year before
and um we're still seeing a shortage of
inventory so even if the recession is is
deeper than what it looks like it's
going to be even if the uh
the continued economic garbage out there
inflation everything else continues to
pinch buyers budgets even if all that
happens we don't think we're going to
see prices go down
and it's a good time to sell a house
it's not as good as it was a year ago
but it's still a good time to sell a
house because there's still a shortage
of inventory it's a better time to buy a
house than it was a year ago
because you don't get into one of these
bidding wars and you're not competing
with people
uh
that are putting in offers with no
appraisal uh no contingency on financing
uh if they're getting financing no uh
inspection
uh no nothing we're just gonna buy the
house oh and we're gonna pay more for it
than it's worth than than the appraised
value so in this market you really need
a professional real estate agent by the
way that's true of almost any market but
you really need somebody that has done a
lot of transactions
not your uncle harry or uncle larry that
just got his license somebody done a lot
of transactions go to
ramseysolutions.com
click endorse local providers these are
real estate agents that do a lot of
transactions that we have vetted they're
good people
they are ramsey trusted they know the
business and they can help you navigate
all this weirdness out there and keep
you from getting caught in a pinch
david is with us in l.a hi david how are
you
hey good how you guys doing better than
we deserve what's up
hey two-part question for you guys um so
i graduated about two years ago with my
undergrad in accounting finance
and i've been working now in commercial
real estate um affectionate affordable
housing as an acquisitions analyst
and i'm trying to pinpoint um a
whether i should go back and get my
masters or masters now or weight and
what you thought about online versus in
person or is it just based off like the
quality of the institution like ufc ucla
or should i get like a real estate
specific masters of science versus an
mba i know i just do a lot of yes that's
right what do you need an mba for
um
i want to be more competitive i want to
refine my skills uh step into a
leadership or executive position or run
my own company at some point
and also learn none of those things
require an mba
right um
yeah i mean i guess
i mean you actually think as an analyst
you're doing analyst work you actually
think you're going to learn something
getting an mba that's going to help you
analyze the properties better than
you're analyzing them now
no that's that's why i i knew that in
the back of my head like i don't think
they're going to tell me anything
specific to what i'm doing that's going
to help me yeah better you're just
collecting merit badges
yeah i mean that's what it kind of
seemed like to me but at the same time
it does help to get you like a position
maybe like a black stone or like a a
very big like private equity firm now
that would be true they do like to see
that that would be true yeah
with your cup with the company you're
currently at has nothing to do with
running your own business though
no so are you going to go blackstone are
you going to run your own business
well i figured i would learn from the
best and blackstone's really one of the
biggest asset managers um and they're
getting into this affordable housing
space it's kind of starting to glow um
now with you know
rents increasing and people not making
enough to be able to afford
i'm generalizing a lot i understand it
seems to be growing uh growing up i'm
just challenging your paradigm
yeah i know i like that um and uh
i'm sorry um i missed i missed a
question there i think there was a
question asked with a company you're
currently at is there any type of growth
track for having an mba have they
outlined anything you know that if you
have an mba you make more money or you
know you get more opportunities
um so they so
that's the question i can bring up with
my boss doing our one-on-one but um i
did ask if they would help compensate
for it because that's obviously a big
factor they're really expensive programs
and um he said he wasn't sure and he's
going to get back to me
on it
um
but uh i mean i i know you can't really
trust the marketing on some of these
programs like
ucla has a femba it's a fully employed
mba program and they show that their
average
starting is like 156. i love that you
ask your boss your boss that because um
you know a lot of times companies will
offer some sort of tuition reimbursement
or assistance um if you're wanting to
get mpa an mba and it helps you within
that company but i also agree with dave
you don't necessarily need it i think
it's super important to question you
know where is this leading and is it
necessary in my journey all right let me
go back a couple steps then okay number
one mba programs are generally excellent
programs
and uh it generally will help you with
if nothing else it'll really enhance
your
your strategic thought
almost all mba programs lean in on
teaching critical thinking around
strategic thought and they do a great
job so for someone like me that's an
entrepreneur where my natural tendency
is more tactical than strategic having
some mbas around me is a really good
thing
and i've got a bunch of them on our team
here
i didn't hire them because they have
mbas but i learned from them a strategic
thought that i didn't know so it's good
for that you can overpay for it where
you go to school doesn't matter you're
going to get a good lineup wherever and
no i would not pay big money for one
under any circumstances
number two i don't want this i don't
want you to think this is causing you to
become successful
uh it might get you in the door at
blackrock that might be real
other than that
it's not the secret to your success
um i think you probably ought to go get
one but i think you're giving it too
much credit
i think you're giving it more power than
it actually has it's not the secret
sauce dude you are
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care
that's why we call them ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free homeownership
and churchill is here to help go to
their site
churchillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
[Music]
christina ellis number one best-selling
author and ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
two five 825-5225 the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage chris
and susan are with us hey guys how are
you hi dave hi christine hi guys welcome
where do you guys live
mesa arizona oh welcome to nashville
where we have humidity
we found that out very briefly that's a
different kind of heat yeah so uh fun
how much debt have you guys paid off
371 thousand dollars way to go and how
long did this take
almost seven years good for you and your
range of income during that time we
started right around a hundred thousand
and uh i would say almost tripled that
so up to about 300 yeah cool what do you
all do for a living
i'm in
procurement and i'm in food distribution
and i do hr generalist work for a tech
company and i'm a photographer oh you're
busy okay wow way to go cool so seven
years 371 000 you pay off your house
we paid off our house at where people
some weirdos in the house i love it so
what's this house worth
um this morning i looked at it eight
hundred and seventy four thousand
dollars i love it
it's all yours
all our 100
very cool how much in your retirement
accounts
um about 260. okay so your baby steps
millionaires we are you did it we are
how old are you two
i'm 48
and i'm 46. before you were 50. yes
house was paid for and you're
millionaires that was our goal dave i'm
so proud of y'all way to go man living
the dream thank you very cool so what
started this process seven years ago
tell us your whole story and how you got
connected to ramsay yeah we were
actually gifted financial peace
university by a former employee of yours
um who's here with us today christy
albers oh really chris she's here
she's hiding around the corner
she gifted it to us and we honestly
didn't think that we had a problem with
our finances when we looked around at
our friends
we didn't have school loan debt and so
we just had a minimum of credit card
debt and so we really didn't think we
were in bad shape but then when we
started the classes we realized that we
needed to have a much larger
vision for our future
and when we started kind of running the
numbers we realized that our age we
didn't really have time to spare oh
a little wake-up call then big wake-up
call okay all right so you sit down and
run the numbers you go through financial
peace university and you say uh we not
only can do this but we need to yeah
absolutely absolutely and and we
actually had a lot of fun i mean we may
be a little different than some of the
folks that you have on we had a lot of
fun with it
um we really enjoyed the goal setting
and
we enjoyed being a little competitive
with each other since i had my side
photography business it was kind of fun
at the end of a month to sit down and
throw down another thousand dollars or
something
she got she got very lucky to marry
somebody who loves spreadsheets
absolutely number one the nerd
he did the spreadsheets i did three jobs
so you know
[Laughter]
so we uh we loved we loved the program
we actually thrived with boundaries and
i think we both learned that during the
course of
going through our journey
um but was what was really interesting
is we would be making all this progress
and then all of a sudden it would feel
like we hit like a roadblock
and we didn't really understand why
because we were totally in alignment
with where we were going and how we were
getting there
um
and so we'd step back and we'd look at
what we were doing and we would realize
that we had missed a vital piece of your
plan oh
and it may have been a small one but it
was vital um
you know when we got married i didn't
get married i was almost 40 years old so
i never even thought about
combining our bank accounts
it's not that i was trying to be you
know intentionally obstinate
but it just never it never crossed my
mind that that was something that i
should do
and so we would have budget meetings and
they would feel tense and they shouldn't
have because we were completely aligned
with where we were going but then we
took a step back and went wait we never
merged our bank accounts what are we
doing and so we would take a step back
do a course correction and all of a
sudden greece on the wheels we were
rolling again
so we had several of those moments and
um so you all had a pretty big income
jump um were you just working like crazy
like what all did you guys do to get out
of debt that's all it's seven years is a
long time right so
i mean
a lot of that's career progression right
and then you know susan just
working multiple jobs and as a
photographer she's just trying to to get
multiple photography jobs so she's just
rocking and rolling like she said she'd
throw an extra thousand dollars a month
in and just
um she gets great thrill out of traction
i really do it's awesome i really do i
really do yeah yeah it is a game yeah it
is a game absolutely
i love it
what would you tell people is the key
of all the amazing things you all
learned all the hustling you did what's
the key to getting out of debt
i mean the the biggest key for me was
all these little course corrections that
we did during the journey
um
led to one of the biggest alignments
that we had to do not only with the
ramsey plan but with the lord
and that came the beginning of this year
so we were already six years into our
journey
and
in february our church um which if it's
okay it's christ church of the valley
yeah we love those guys yeah yeah and so
pastor ashley wooldridge he did his
annual
uh tithing message
and he challenged all the members of the
church that weren't already tithing the
full ten percent
to
to do it for three months and then see
what the lord did in your life
and so
chris and i talked about it and we had
always given what we belie believed was
quite generously to the church
but we weren't we we weren't tithing we
were tipping really was what it came
down to
we thought we were being obedient um but
really
you know it really put us over
over the edge
um
we were
so close to paying off the house and
when i say so close 100 000 or what but
really starting to tithe
really made that jump and
if you look at the numbers it shouldn't
have worked yeah but it did it
absolutely worked we we decided um we
decided in march to to take the church
up on the challenge and to finally get
completely aligned with your plan
because that was another one of those we
did that class and we went oh yeah we
give check
but we weren't being fully obedient
and so we made the decision in march to
do that and i would say it wasn't two
weeks later
um and we originally were projected to
pay off our home in october of this year
no next year no
october of next year sorry and as we
made all these course corrections it we
were able to speed up the progress and
speed up the progress until it was
october of this year that we were going
to pay off the house and
we were even so confident in that date
that we submitted an application to come
on the show
at the end of the year and do our screen
and then in march when we decided to
fully tithe and fully be obedient to the
lord
uh about two weeks later chris text me
and said i just looked at the numbers
and we can actually do this now
and
i want to be really clear
that it wasn't that we started tithing
and then ran into some kind of windfall
no we didn't inherit money we didn't
find money in fact our income may have
gone down a little bit because chris
made a career change
but there was a clarity that came over
us
that all of a sudden these numbers that
were in all these different piles yeah
perspective
and so we called your team here and we
said just kidding
up
yes and dawn was awesome and she got us
she got us right in very cool dawn's
amazing all right baby steps
millionaires book for you that's uh well
that's what you are the way to go i'm so
proud of y'all you're an amazing people
beautiful beautiful beautiful also a
total money makeover book for you to
give away to someone and bless them you
know the stories now and financial peace
university with the brand new videos in
it with dr john dolony and george
campbell rachel and me and the best best
series we've ever done so and uh tell
pastor we said hello we love that church
and him as well it's a wonderful people
count it down guys chris and susan mesa
arizona 371 thousand in seven years a a
debt-free scream
three
two
one we're dead
[Music]
[Applause]
that's incredible it's powerful
man oh man oh man this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
christina ellis number one best-selling
author
ramsey personality is my co-host today
open phone is a triple eight eight two
five five
two two five
article handed to us by kelly as she's
producing the show today as sports
betting grows
states tackle
teenage
problem gambling
with online and retail sports betting
now legal in more than 30 states the
portrait of a new
problem gambler is emerging the high
school student although the legal age
for gambling is 18 to 21 depending on
the state between 60 and 80 percent of
high school students report having
gambled for money
in the past year according to the
national council on problem gambling the
group says the pandemic and easy access
to online gambling have heightened risks
for young adults four to six percent of
high schoolers are considered addicted
to gambling the group says the
percentage of high school students with
a gambling problem is double that of
adults research has found
and as sports betting becomes pervasive
in brick and mortar betting parlors and
often for anyone with a cell phone state
gambling addiction services are
underfunded kids who have problems fall
through the cracks says the person doing
the
doing the study
so
uh it's a problem oh four to six percent
that just
blows my mind and breaks my heart
well uh sports betting
the advertising budget for it is
astronomical obviously we've seen
caesar and all the other super bowl ads
that are running and ads running around
this stuff pushing pushing pushing
pushing pushing
and um
it's all based on a cool factor
you know fanduel it's it's you're cool
if your sports betting because you're up
on sports and you're a player you know
and so uh mix
those things with being a high school
student and you have a disaster on your
hands
and parents that don't know what the
flip your kids are doing online
what in the world mom and dad
so well i can't monitor everything then
then don't let them i mean oh my gosh
well this younger generation seems to
have such a
um
a drive and a curiosity around money
which in many senses is good if they're
wanting to join the ramsey plan and do
investing the right way but we see so
many kids getting involved with crypto
and this and it's just like there's so
much confusion it's like if we can
channel that desire to learn about money
and invest and build wealth into really
stable methods that's awesome but this
well what you've got is people who are
emotionally immature they're teenagers
they're physically immature they're
teenagers their brains aren't fully
developed
and you've got a an entire generation
that has never known a day without a
cell phone
without a connection to the internet
that it's all it's existed and been
prevalent in their lives their entire
lives so it's very normalized
and then mix in the highly addictive
addictive behavior of gambling oh and
mix in ease of access and anonymity and
the ability to do it in secret
in a deceptive way
and you have a real recipe for disaster
here yeah so what would you say a parent
should do if they find out that their
kid is involved with this
well here's the thing we do know the
we work with
people who have financial problems in
portions of our business not all of our
business but we work with wealthy people
and we work with people with financial
problems
we know that personal finance is 80
behavior we also when we see the
problems um we know this 100
of addicts
have financial trouble
eventually
100 percent
because it screws up your life it
becomes your god and it sucks all the
the actual available financial resources
out of your life and channels them
towards this destructive behavior the
fastest so we deal with ethics all the
time is what i'm saying we're not
specialists in helping people with
addictions but we deal with addicts all
the time because of their money stuff
and so we watch these behaviors the
fastest growing addiction in north
america right now by far is online porn
it is over the top online pornography
now makes more
total revenue in america than all
professional sporting events combined
football
nascar
baseball
basketball
add it all up it doesn't even make it it
doesn't even come close to online porn
it is
blowing up and guess who else that's
affecting the same exact age group okay
it's affecting everyone
but this same exact age group and all
kinds of data on the problems that that
presents
the second fastest growing addiction in
north america
gambling
see you think you think when you say
addiction you think of alcohol
cocaine
crack
whatever and they're all there the old
classic addictions are still around
without a doubt
but they're no but they're not online
accessible
and these online accessible addictions
are the ones that have scaled
and are sneaky and they sneak into
people's lives
and they're easy to ha easier to hide
until they're not
until it blows up and they go everywhere
with you
i have a friend of mine who has a kid
that's in his 30s
and the kid uh
you know
he's like 400 000 dollars in that on the
sports betting
oh my before they figured out what's
going on he's losing everything he's
lost his job he's probably going to lose
his little wife
she's about had it you know and he's
destroyed his life but he got sucked
into these things and he called me up
and he's like can you help me i'm like
well yeah i can help but you're not
going to like the
solutions because my solutions are
pretty brutal because it's a pretty
brutal situation
so we're going to treat him like he's a
freaking addict because baby he is an
addict and 100 of addicts go broke 100
are manipulative and 100 lie
and so it's a it's a brutal business to
get in the get in the dust with those
folk yeah and help them to help them to
love them well it requires a tremendous
amount of courage and strength on their
part and the people that are helping
them
so this is so dangerous it's
unbelievable what would i do
i would just shut down the internet you
know there'd just be no access there'd
be no cell phones um
you have a you you know it would be like
okay what would i do to a 16 year old
who was um
uh
you know caught driving a car with
cocaine in the trunk
i'd take away the car if the law didn't
i would i'd be done okay you can't you
can't apparently you don't get that
these things don't go together uh you
don't get to have one
and uh because i love you so much i'm
going to bar you from access to things
that are going to kill you
and whether it's a vehicle or a cell
phone
or online presence or avatar or whatever
it is i cut out of your dadgum life
because i love you so much because you
is out of control puppy
you know and that's that's what
man
and that is love even though your your
kid may not feel it in the moment they
may they won't feel it very upset in the
moment that's that's love that's very
loving
but it's not the problem is it's a
little difficult to tell your kid not
the sports bet when you are
it's a little difficult to you know tell
your kid not to do crack when you are
um and you know well man i know what my
dad does i know what my mom does you
know
it's a little difficult and so because
you know rachel always says more is
caught than taught so if you're working
running a life that's character based
and isn't tied into this garbage then
you're you can ease it's more easily
then
it's it's easier for you to take a
stance and go
i just love you too much to let you kill
yourself
i'm not gonna do it because i'm still
your parent i'm still in charge
as long as you're 16 years old you live
in my house i can take you out and make
another one looks just like you you know
we're not doing this
we're not going to live this way
that's old-school parenting i understand
some of you people think that your
children have freedom they don't they're
children
your is your job to protect them from
everything including themselves and some
of your parents are wusses
you're complete wusses and you've got to
stand up and just go no cell phones i
mean we're talking about cell phones in
general at the break and you got little
babies and you're going what am i going
to do when our my kids get to this age
yeah oh man
yeah i was talking to somebody recently
and they were talking about how their
third grader was the only one without a
cell phone and i was like whoa i thought
we had at least till middle school till
we had to deal with that
nope
yeah so i mean these things are
the phone in and of itself is not evil
but it is a gateway to evil
and so if you can't keep the gate shut
then uh we'll just not let you hang
around the gate that's a pretty simple
thing but this is dangerous stuff right
here and really these companies these
sports betting companies it's on them
too because they got nothing in there to
keep you from doing it they got no
blockers at all and so somebody's gonna
end up with a class-action lawsuit
shutting old caesar down if they don't
quit screwing around with these kids
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships we're so glad you're here
america thank you for joining us
christina ellis number one best-selling
author and ramsay personality is my
co-host today you jump in we'll talk
about your life and your money the phone
number triple eight eight two five five
two two five frank is in tallahassee
florida to start off this hour hi frank
how are you
hey dave thank christina thank you for
taking my call sure what's up how are
you guys doing good i got a quick
question uh me and my wife are on baby
step three uh we make combined total of
a little over 58 a year uh
we're debt-free besides our mortgage
six uh two
to 216k
um moment that you said baby steps oh
three you're working on your emergency
fund
yeah oh i'm sorry sir we do have an
emergency fund so you're on baby step
forward oh yeah
yes sir i believe i'm sorry okay
okay
so i'm just trying to make sure i know
where you are it's all good
yes sir um
we have a i have a personal injury
settlement that's coming in um
a little over 100k and i'm trying to
find the best way to
where to place this money out so i don't
mess it up now me and my wife we don't
have a uh
401k or ira ira we're a little bit uh
starting behind with that
our jobs don't offer that uh so we know
i've been doing some research and
listening to you guys talk about ira
accounts and things like that so we know
we want to put some in there but we can
only put a certain amount in that
account but we're just trying to figure
out what's the best way to do with the
rest of the money work put it on the
house or or we'll go from there
so do you how much do you have left on
your house right now
you said uh
216. all right so y'all are in baby
steps four through six which baby step
four is saving fifteen percent for
retirement so i love that you're looking
into an ira um and starting to figure
out what you wanna do with retirement
savings because that's the first place
we want you to stop do you all have kids
uh we have three uh
two of them they're about to be seniors
this year um
one of them
has well one of them has no ambition
doing the college thing they want to get
a trade just like plumbing or carpentry
work they're having one of them having a
hard time in school and the other one is
my special needs daughter uh and so she
is thinking about just doing daycare
okay
so baby step five is saving for your
kids college you all have three kids
i'll be curious to get dave's take on um
how much should go towards that and then
baby step six is paying off your house
so um
100k is a good amount dave what do you
think in terms of the
split now are you uh are you healed from
the injury
no sir um i well i did 20 years of
construction um now i i worked two jobs
i had two jobs now i basically have one
now um so i'm i'm able to work but it's
the the i'm limited to the kind of work
i can do
okay or do you have future surgeries
on this injury or any ongoing medical
bills
no sir okay so we don't need to allocate
any of this money to the injury itself
uh no sir okay all right and how much do
you all have in your emergency fund
right now
a little over 17k good for you
well you've done a really good job to
this point and you're doing a really
good job because a lot of people that
get a settlement check like this feel
like they hit the lottery and you're you
instead are of being all emotional and
woohoo and throwing confetti up you're
like okay this feels like a
responsibility
as much as a blessing and you're
approaching it with a lot of maturity
way to go
good stuff thank you sir so um yeah i'm
i'm with christine i i would do a couple
of roth iras and set that up to where
you've got automatically that thousand
dollars a month or so coming out
probably don't have to be quite that
much in the future uh out of your budget
you want to put 15 percent of your 60k
aside so that's not going to be quite
that much but um
you know let's make sure we're doing
roths automatically drafted and out of
your budget going forward kids college
let's just say okay what do we need for
kids college let's just look at it okay
special needs daughters going into
daycare we don't have to worry about any
funding of that it sounds like
probably do need to pay for some tech
school for the boy that's going to be a
plumber or some kind of technical
training if he would go get some
community or some tech school uh
you know type certifications it'll
probably advance his career in that in
the plumbing field wouldn't it
yes sir i think with it from what
they're telling me because he's a junior
in high school now that they can he can
go to a trade school his senior year and
he'll start trading him for uh training
him for outside work outside in the
fields yeah i would just look into post
high school education
for his field
and say what's that going to cost and
let's set aside some money for that
because i'm a firm believer that whether
you go to college or whether you're
going to the trades doesn't matter to me
but you need to get smarter than just
high school
everyone needs to do something after
high school train for something
okay
because the data is there that you know
if you go to two-year uh three-year
diesel mechanic school you make six
figures okay in the trade so or you
wanna be a welder
and you go to trade school that's fine
but let's put that into the budget here
into this and say okay we need ten
thousand bucks for this kid to do this
so we're going to set that aside we're
going to set aside 12 000 for two roth
iras we're going to set aside and then
i'm going to look at the the third one
and go okay we're going to plan for that
one maybe to go to college
and so what are we going to budget for
that and we're going to set some money
aside for that and then the rest of this
i'm putting towards the house
yes sir i'm probably also going to
budget about 10 grand just to go do
something fun
gotcha sounds like you guys have been
through hell you could use a little fun
oh yeah
that's yeah definitely that um and just
so happens uh you know i've been
following your your uh your your baby
steps and and thank you for changing my
life my wife's life uh and we just had a
scare with the roof so we're gonna have
to get our roof replaced as well but i
know i have the emergency fund for that
well you don't even have to use it i can
use some of that hundred and not touch
it for that
if you want because you're gonna turn
and put the emergency fund back out of
the hundred if you use it so you might
as well
uh but what i'm going to do with the 100
is i'm going to treat it like a monthly
budget i know that sounds weird but i'm
going to say okay here's a hundred now i
need to give every one of those dollars
an assignment and we were just doing
that here okay 10 for fun 10 for
plumbing
uh you know 12 for two roth iras we're
gonna get the roth set up see what i'm
doing i'm starting to spend this money
in a sense on paper like i'm doing a
budget
yes and so go ahead and write that write
it out with your wife and say okay and
we're gonna fix the roof and that's
gonna be six and we're gonna you know
this car needs to be upgraded and that's
gonna be 10 or 11 or two or whatever it
is or not
and then we're go the rest of it we're
going to throw at the house um
uh and but but if you'll go ahead and
and
based on the baby steps and based on
your household goals give all of these
dollars an assignment before the check
gets there it's a lot easier
once it gets there because what happens
when you do that is you realize it's not
that much money
when you hear a hundred thousand bucks
man i remember remember the first time i
thought somebody's gonna send me a
hundred thousand bucks i about went
crazy i thought that's so much money and
then once you get it it's not
it just it it just goes i mean it's just
not it sounds like it's a lot and it is
it's more than i used you know but but
but
yeah
it's you need it calms you down to give
every one of these dollars an assignment
before the check gets there don't wail
the check gets there to do it you'll
make mistakes
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
christina ellis ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today open phones a triple eight
eight two five five
two two five
have you noticed that the stock market
is down
well if you looked at it you noticed
and some people are more than just
noticing they're like stressed out
freaked out going oh my gosh i'm in
freak out mode
a little drama queen action going right
yeah well
it needs somebody in your corner when
this stuff's going on that can talk you
off the ledge so to speak
you need someone to walk with you talk
with you teach you and that way you
don't jump into the market now the
market at exactly the wrong times which
is what your emotion will cause you to
do
the data shows that the people who work
with an investing with an investing
professional actually end up making more
money mainly because they stay invested
you know if the investing professional
doesn't do anything except keep you from
cashing in at exactly the wrong times
they will make you more money than they
cost if that's all they do and of course
they do a lot more than that they teach
you about it you make different
decisions on taxes all kinds of things
we recommend you work with what we call
a smart investor pro
smart vista pros are people that they're
investing professionals that we have
vetted that will work with you
one-on-one with the heart of a teacher
go to ramseysolutions.com smartvestor
you can find a list of these people that
we endorse that we recommend the ramsey
solutions way smartvestor pros are
everywhere ramsey solutions dot com
slash smart vester our question of the
day comes from blinds.com find out for
yourself why blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsey to get the best deal
today's question comes from noah in
arizona i'm about to graduate from high
school i have no credit card and i was
wondering how i can prove that i can pay
my bills on time to an apartment owner
to get a lease if i haven't started any
major bills yet the only bills i pay so
far is car insurance do you have any
guidance
well you know good on you for thinking
about that now you sound like one of our
foundation students who are getting that
stuff in order early on which is awesome
um one of the biggest things you're
going to going to want to see is your
income so i would really focus on that
early on you know they're going to want
to see a steady income history which i
know that can be hard straight out of
high school if you start working early
on maybe live somewhere with your
parents for a bit and have that income
history that's great but also look into
options like having roommates i mean you
may not qualify for an apartment
straight away if you don't have that
steady job and proof that you can pay
but you could always get a roommate
who's got a lease and you can sign on
and get a room with them so noah what's
interesting is is this is one of the
most pervasive
myths out there
it's an absolute lie
you have to have a credit score to run
an apartment
you just don't
it's a lie
you know how we know we took one of our
ramsey personalities got them on the
phone put it on youtube and they called
27 apartment complexes and said hey i'm
moving to nashville for my first job
i don't have anything except a job i
have never borrowed any money i don't
have any credit score is that okay can i
run an apartment there and they're like
yeah sure
do i have to do anything special
some of them said you need to put up a
little larger deposit
um
some of them said we need to see your
w-2 we need to see a you know when you
see a pay stub from the new job
uh well i haven't ever borrowed any
money i don't have a credit score no
problem
no problem
out of 27 three of them
had a problem
three it's good odds and these were like
regular apartment complexes corporate
management corporate ownership all this
stuff so this idea that you have to have
a credit score to run an apartment is
absolute bullcrap
now some yeah that's true
it is harder to rent a car with a debit
card than it is to rent an apartment
with no credit score
much harder
much harder
so this is just one of those things that
people this mythology that people tell
we used to call it in the legal world
they call it street law everybody thinks
they know what the law is because they
heard something one time on matlock you
know and they don't know anything about
the law but everybody then starts to
believe this myth this lie and it's
spread around you know here's the thing
noah call 20 apartment complexes and
prove me wrong
you're going to find three of them won't
let you in
and 17 of them will some of them want a
higher deposit they all want what
christina said they want proof of income
they just want to know you can pay the
bill if apartment complexes never rented
to young people doing their first job
they'd have no customers
old people that have been on the job 25
years are not in apartment complexes
people most of the time they're not the
primary customer anyway okay so
i just i kind of believed it
and then anthony o'neil that used to be
one of our personalities sat down dialed
the phone and the youtube of him died on
that phone nope nope nope nope nope it's
humorous it's so ridiculous
and it because it's one of these things
that's just widely believed to be true
that is an absolute lie
that's humorous to me
that this the emperor has no clothes
thing we all believe that it's this way
and we're afraid to say out loud that
it's not until you prove them with
actual data
and so just just amazing so let that
myth be busted there we go pop that
puppy all right brittany's with us
brittany's in cincinnati how are you
brittany
i am better than i deserve dave good how
can we help
i am calling to ask if we should pull
from the emergency fund to help pay off
our house is it an emergency
no why is it called an emergency fund
then
exactly so we were a little bit hesitant
because we received an inheritance check
and with that check
and what we have in our checking in our
savings
including the emergency
we could pay off our house and pull
okay so how much do you owe on your
house
um after august we will owe
61 000. and how much was the inheritance
check
25 000.
okay and how much do you have in your
emergency fund
we have in that account 20 000 but only
12 year mark for emergency
okay so you have a 12 000 emergency fund
yes and then in our checking accounts we
have twenty thousand dollars
okay well the twenty thousand from your
checking and the eight thousand that is
not earmarked as an emergency fund are
not in this discussion that's all going
towards the house right that gets you
there though doesn't it
almost
almost yeah and then what's your
household income
um it's 70 a little over 76 000
yeah well we do not recommend you go
below the 12
which is your emergency fund
so the answer is no we don't use your
emergency fund to pay off your house now
if you had an emergency fund there was
three to six months of expenses and you
were on the six-month side and you
wanted to cheat back to the three-month
side for a little bit
and that would do it but that won't do
it here number one number two your
emergency fund is not huge
twelve thousand twelve thousand is not
huge
yeah we're very frugal yeah so 12 000 is
good i'm happy with that but i wouldn't
go below that
okay so what do you think christine
yeah i agree i think i love that you
want to pay off the house and i think
that's awesome
to be in baby step seven but i think i
would just take it a little bit slower
to stay safe i wouldn't i wouldn't
jeopardize the emergency fund because
again
you you could be you know have a roof
problem or a leak and then all of a
sudden you're in a whole nother
different issue so
i love keep the gas on the pedal and
keep going forward but just maybe slow
it down just a tad bit
how much was the inheritance again
um well we've had several portions but
this time was 25 000. okay
all right so you have 53
000 if you don't touch the 12 and you
need 61.
yeah so you're within
eight thousand dollars and you make
seventy thousand dollars
so you're going to pay off the house by
the first of the year anyway give or
take
yes yeah
so no we're not going below the
emergency fund because all it does is
take it takes about six months off this
process and you're within reach if you
got something else you can sell that you
want to to pay off the house i'm okay
with that but i'm not going i'm not
going into the emergency fund let me
tell you what when you mess with your
emergency fund for something that's not
an emergency it's sending an engraved
invitation to murphy
saying murphy come screw with my life
because he will he's standing there
ready to come
and you just open the murphy gate and
let him in don't do that
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
my
[Music]
so
[Music]
christina ellis number one best-selling
author ramsey personality is my co-host
teresa is with us in
from lincoln nebraska on the debt free
stage how are you good how are you doing
bit of a haul from lincoln to nashville
it was a long drive
well welcome how much debt did you pay
off forty six thousand three hundred and
three dollars way to go and how long did
this take you 13 months good for you and
your range of income during that time uh
started at 39 and went to 79 000. wow
very cool what kind of debt was the 46 i
had student loans a car loan
uh credit card debt
everything you were kind of normal a
little bit
so uh what happened and made you weird
you i mean you got lined up on this
ramsey stuff tell us the story so i
actually met my current boyfriend
and we went on our first date and yes we
did talk about money
he was real romantic
it was it was natural
he asked me though what my goal was for
vet and i told him i wanted to be
debt-free before i was 30. at the time i
was 25.
i was about to turn 26. and he was like
okay yeah you know he told me about you
told me how he came on here two years
ago he did his scream
he's debt-free told me his life i was
like okay like this guy's debt free he's
kind of attractive yeah exactly it
processed
a couple weeks later he gifted me the
total money makeover read it in like a
day subtle as a brick through a window
isn't he
once he gifted it i read it it clicked
and i was like nope i've got to do this
so i started
hustling i sold a truck i had
i had a 77 chevy that i sold was my baby
and i told him i will never sell this
truck i'll never get rid of this this is
not going anywhere what did it sell for
4 500.
it was hard i still to this day i'm like
i'm getting that thing back
one day
i had a car i sold that i think that's
when he took me seriously that i was
serious about getting out of debt at
that point because he was like wow she
sold her truck i told him i'm never
sawing this thing finally saw my truck
sold my car
after that i started hustling just
started working before work full-time
job after work
and after that i just
once i got into it it was a competition
and i couldn't stop with myself i was
like oh i'm going to beat this 17 months
i'm going to beat this 15 months i'm
going to beat it even more than that and
i just kept going and going and going
and then once i got done it was like i'm
done
really
man i love that i was going to ask you
what was the hardest part but it sounds
like the truck
the truck was hard yes in the beginning
but just continually going was really
hard for me you know after so long
you're just like i'm so tired i'm tired
of working fifteen seconds what do you
do for a living i'm a compliance analyst
for an energy company so you had extra
hours doing that or you picked up side
gigs side gigs what was the best paying
side hustle um probably grocery delivery
yeah i did it all i did i think i had
like eight of them at one point in time
but
what everything i could i'm not afraid
of hard work are you nope
and you did this pretty quick too 13
months that's that's impressive yeah i
think when i started it was 16 months
and i was like nope can't do that and my
original goal was 11 but
i blew a [ __ ] in my car so i had to
get another car
and just bunch of stuff happen medical
bills and other things piled on top of
that so so you're working like crazy
you're selling things like crazy did
people think you were crazy oh yeah
people kept asking me why are you
working so much why are you doing this
why what are you doing why and it just
was clear to me i understood why i
wanted that lifestyle i was sick and
tired of
constantly making payments not being
able to make those payments or only
having you know 50 bucks at the end of
the day to go and get groceries i was
just tired of that lifestyle i didn't
want to do it and now i mean when i blew
that transmission in that car before
that would have been the end of the
world i would have been crying and
everywhere i still remember that day i
called him and i was like just blew the
[ __ ] he's like what and we're like
okay we'll figure it out and i was like
all right yeah it's cool we'll get a new
car in a matter of moments we had
another one lined up and ready to go and
it was like just i was like wow this is
what it feels like to have that freedom
to not stress and not have to put
yourself backwards and
use a credit card to do it or get a loan
to do it as well
yeah because it's amazing it goes from
being like this life-altering emergency
to an inconvenience it's like oh man
that's unfortunate but we can we can
afford this
so for somebody who's on the fence who's
thinking about starting the baby steps
who has a lot of debt what would you
tell them right now
figure out your why and what motivates
you and push to get to that goal mm-hmm
you know i i'm a little bit on it with
somebody that went through financial
pieces
that works too but hey i i got fpu on my
own i went through it all i watched him
religiously took notes i'm a no person
wow so i did that on my own after he
gave me the book and after that it just
clicked in my mind and i was like man
what am i doing
this is crazy i'm i'm working too hard
to be living this
stressful
you know
yeah you're you're amazing well done
girl you got after it i love it so proud
of you so you're
you got out of debt by
26 is that what you said
um no 27. just would have turned 27.
okay all right way to go just shy not
even 30 years old though nope beat that
you are free you are free which i mean
previously you thought you were just
going to be there your whole life yeah i
i've honestly never lived a life of not
having debt yeah this is the first and i
have never felt more free you know
coming up here would have been super
stressed about oh let's go out to eat no
no no like we got to stick to this
budget we're we're on a trip we're still
on a budget though i mean we're on a
budget but we're still having fun we're
still being able to go and do what we
want we swipe the car or debit card or
cash when we go to dinner or whatever we
do so
i love that feeling it's amazing i would
never go back to that completely in
control yeah instead of out of control
and don't know what's going to happen
exactly the um
ambient
anxiety that just hangs in the air
around you when you don't have a plan
and you're not executing uh even when
you're not out of debt yet once you got
the plan the anxiety drops off oh yeah
because you just like came on like when
the transmission hit and all that it's
the same thing it just game on came on
came on came on
so this is your biggest cheerleader i
assume him this was my biggest
cheerleader yep okay my mom and my
sister were extremely supportive they're
listening right now okay did they think
you were crazy or they and they still
supported you or they thought yeah
finally she's gonna do this i think they
thought i was a little bit crazy for how
much i was working
and oh you need to slow down but at the
end of the day they knew exactly why i
was doing it too
you know just to have that freedom my
stress levels my anxiety levels it's
like
to a healthy right now yeah you know not
where i was at where i couldn't
you know it's just it was really big
struggle and right before i happened to
do this i moved into my own apartment
again
i was you know going through crazy time
in life and there's just i couldn't even
afford i mean at the end of that month i
think i had like 50 bucks for groceries
so it was like
doing what i could with friends to try
and you know like hey i'll babysit your
kids but then that means i get a meal or
something so i'm not having to stress
about the money and now it's like i
don't even stress about it at all yeah i
bet they're so proud of you you are a
walking breathing example i think that
is awesome yeah very well done you're a
rock star we're proud of you thank you
very very cool good stuff good stuff
excellent job all right now that you've
done it what do you tell people the key
to getting out of that is
don't give up just keep going
you know why you're doing it you know
what you want what was the low point
when you almost gave up oh i think it
was probably like
the last final months it was just that
point where i was like i'm so tired i'm
exhausted i was sleeping minimal hours
because i was working like crazy and it
was just that hard internal drive to not
you know i couldn't stop i knew i
couldn't stop but i didn't want to keep
going either but i knew i didn't want to
be in debt so i was like choose your
hard what's your heart going to be yeah
either work or
you know do your fun and whatever but at
the end of the day going through and
having fun
didn't make me happy because i knew i
was doing it on debt or
it was going to catch up to me later on
so getting that out of the way it was
just
yeah there's your lock for now choose
your heart i love that i'm going to have
one choose it
got a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you that's the next chapter in your
story you're going to be one no question
about it in my mind a copy of total
money makeover for you to give away
maybe some of those naysayers need to
need some help and a financial peace
university membership as well and you've
been through it but maybe you can give
that away and help somebody very proud
of you charissa lincoln nebraska 46 000
paid off in 13 months make it 39-79
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three
two
one
i'm debt-free
yeah
this is how it's done
[Applause]
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day romans 12 13
take a constant interest in the needs of
god's beloved people and respond by
helping them and eagerly welcome people
as guests into your home
robert lewis stevenson said don't judge
each day by the harvest you reap but by
the seeds
you plant
jackie is with us in honolulu hi jackie
welcome to the ramsay show
hello how are y'all better than we
deserve what's up in your world
uh well we're um me and my husband we're
doing good um we i just have a question
as to where to put the savings that we
have maybe yes you guys can help us out
um we have combined 47k in debt and also
we are planning an actual wedding next
year
in wedding and honeymoon we want to
spend no more than 10k
um i have saved up 19k that i've had
since before we got together and i want
to put that to worse or dead
but my husband thinks that we should put
it towards the wedding and then just
keep the remaining that's an emergency
fund so we're kind of debating as to
where to put the money um and i just
want to see if you guys can give us some
advice
what's your household income going to be
after you're married
uh well we got married in court so we're
together now we just got both got a
promotion so together we're gonna make
170k
you got married what uh we've been
married for 10 months but it was only a
court wedding so we want to have an
actual wedding next year that our family
can be there because their parents were
sick so they weren't able to be there
gotcha so you won't have a celebration
but you're married yeah and i want to
get married to church because i'm
catholic so i still have to do that so
yeah okay that's fine
that's fine all right so now what is
your household income today then
uh together is 170k
170 000. wow you make a lot of money to
be this broke
uh well i mean i technically didn't
really have much debt but now we're
married so it's ours
and you're wanting to know
which order to pay off the debt is that
the question yeah because i have 19k in
savings and i wanted to pay off my car
and that will leave me 5k
but now with him he has 33k and dead
motorcycle and student loans and we also
have a wedding coming up
when is the celebrate when is the
wedding celebration planned
uh it's planned for next year in
september
the this coming september or a year from
september
a year from now so 2023 september a lot
of time to save for that wedding
well and especially with that income
yeah especially that income i think you
can knock out the debt well before the
wedding
um and in terms of what order we
recommend the debt snowball which is
where you list your debts from smallest
to largest regardless of the interest
rates and you start paying on that
smallest debt with aggression you want
to pour everything into that while
paying minimum payments on the rest and
then you're going to pay that off and
then you're going to take the payment
from that and pay off the next debt and
put all of your aggression into that
next step and it kind of builds up like
a snowball rolling downhill
so yeah definitely starting with that
smallest debt is where we want you so
jackie let's talk to him about this let
me throw out some numbers to you if i
got these right tell me if i got them
right
okay you have forty seven thousand
dollars in debt and you need ten
thousand for a wedding that's fifty
seven thousand dollars
okay so if you had a wedding in
september
14 months from now
and you were debt free
we need 57 000 to do those two things 14
months from now does that sound right to
you
yeah okay you have
twenty thousand dollars nineteen yeah
basically okay
so you only need thirty seven thousand
dollars in fourteen months while making
a hundred and seventy grand
i mean really
i think we can do that
okay um so i would take
uh all but one thousand dollars of the
nineteen
baby step one we teach a thing called
the baby steps baby step one's a
thousand dollars saved baby step two is
pay off all of your debts smallest to
largest so i'm going to put 18 000 on
the 47 000 worth of debt
tomorrow
tonight
at on the computer whatever we do okay
i'm gonna get on a written budget and
the two of you are gonna be on beans and
rice rice and beans
no eating out no vacations no frills
we're getting out of debt and we're
saving for a wedding
and if you can't save or move 37 000 out
of 170 in 14 months something's wrong
with you people
yeah really i mean
that leaves you 130 000 bucks to live on
yeah i mean hawaii is expensive come on
you can get out of it come on 130 grand
you can't live on 130 grand
no yeah we can okay
that leaves you 40 to pay off debt and
you'll be debt free
easy that's like a hot knife through
butter kiddo well it's just for a season
too it's not forever it's just for this
one little period of time so the point
is you can be debt-free and have the
money for the wedding easily by one year
from september
especially given we got 18 000 bucks to
throw at it
now i don't know if you all are going to
do that or not because it sounds like
you guys are just kind of sniffing
around the edges of this stuff you
haven't decided who you want to be yet
and for sure he doesn't want to do it
so you guys got to decide do we want to
be debt-free because here's the point
you can
be debt-free and have a wedding for ten
thousand dollars in september of 23
it's only a question of if you will
mathematically we're all agreeing right
now it's possible
and it is what you should do
so we we know what you should do we know
what you can do the only thing we don't
know is what you will do
okay
yeah i mean i i was thinking of using
the savings but
you know you was telling me we should
keep them for the wedding in an
emergency where were you in the last
five minutes
i mean i i don't know i want to pay it
off okay
all right i'll tell you what i'm gonna
do i'm gonna give you a wedding gift for
your court wedding
and we'll see if it sticks for your
catholic wedding
i'm gonna send you a copy of the total
money makeover you and hubby read that
thing and you're gonna start to figure
out that i'm right okay
you cannot save money at nineteen
thousand dollars while you have a car
debt and all this other debt and your
money's making a half a percent in the
bank and get ahead
you make a hundred and seventy thousand
dollars you spend money like you're in
congress
you're gonna have to get this in control
and until you do you're gonna live a
life of regret you're gonna wake up with
a financial hangover and you're gonna
feel like you're living chaos and
anxiety to anxiety to anxiety like you
do right now and that's why you called
me jackie that's why you call her call
me you call me for that you call
christina because she's nice
well jackie i was going to say two like
i would encourage you all to go on a
date and talk about your why it seems
like right now paying off the debt
doesn't seem like a super huge priority
but like we said earlier it's just a
season like if you can get through this
season and have a so that i think you'll
see that it's worthwhile this isn't
going to be forever you said you want to
get a house and there's different things
you want to do but dream up what that
looks like and think about how's it
gonna feel to be debt-free we had that
debt-free scream earlier and she said
the thing that kept her going was her
why so
live in that for a little bit think of
what it is and think of how it'll feel
and how good it's going to feel the
shortest distance between where you are
right now and wealth
is to get on a plan learn to work
together
and clear this debt so that you've got
the 170 000 you got you make a wonderful
income it'd be a shame
to get into your life have made this
kind of money and have absolutely
nothing to show for it
that'd be a shame
don't do that don't live that life
so you're gonna you're gonna get a sense
of pride a sense of empowerment a sense
of togetherness when you're working
towards a shared goal like christine's
talking about a big why
because i think you could be very very
wealthy in five to seven years if you'll
get your crap together
but not with the conversation i'm having
with you right now
you're just a dog chasing his tail right
now i mean you're just back and forth
back and forth man maybe we need to save
you later listen the deal is we teach
this stuff we've taught it to 10 million
people
this works we've made more millionaires
than anybody you've ever talked to
and that's why the latest best-selling
book is baby steps millionaires because
we show you how to do it now kiddo you
can do this we just looked at the
numbers
the only question is will you that's the
only question remaining you should and
you can but will you
hang on austin i'll pick up and we'll
give you a book
christina good hour well done well done
to kelly to andrew to zach to bend to
austin the team in the booth i am dave
ramsey your host we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
[Music]
have you been inspired to make a change
with your money want to know where to
start take our three-minute money quiz
to get a plan you can follow go to
ramsaysolutions.com and search for get
started to get a plan for your money
[Music]
you